- Throughout his presidency,
my grandfather made it clear that he alone
could fix nothing,
that he alone had no answers.
He had the courage to plainly admit
America's own shortcomings,
to then lay out bold plans
to address those problems
and to ask his fellow Americans for help
in solving them.
And in doing so,
he inspired a generation
to enter public service
and to ask what they could
do for their country.
President Barack Obama
inspired me in the same way.
My life changed in 2008
because a young candidate
was fired up and ready to
go and said that yes we can.
From his first days in
office until his last,
the President consistently
put the national interest
above his own political interest,
while resisting the politics of cynicism
in a system that all
too often encourages it.
He showed me and my generation
what is possible from politics
and gave us a new standard
of political courage
to guide us going forward.
He connected us to one
another with his hope
and his determination.
We all, especially young Americans,
owe a great debt to this
courageous president.